[music]
[applause]
chemistry paris is
like paralysis on one side i am paralyzed on the left side
i still have a bit of rest i think
i got it from a stroke
three months before i
was born so i was born with it
only got worse when she got older and she got worse and
worse because the doctors started to make
the first predictions they
all said a bit in the
direction of a wheelchair
so if you put a daughter in a wheelchair
that's okay for me but my
daughter has a problem with it
then i just experimented wildly i
thought if your body can't do that
a machine will even do it you
have absolutely no technical experience i
knew exactly what i wanted
yes and the nup i started at home at the
kitchen table and tried
to put it together
we  pretty quickly got
a prototype grant at the
technical university in berlin
the device when i put it on now  Carrying it on my
shoulder is my shoulder
posture and when I'm not in
this ditch then there's the
electric around size so I learn I
have
I can remember very well
when my mother gave me the device for the first time
it was 15
and  then of course i
tried it right away i'm that perfect
[music]
it went smoothly within three days
because you said at the end of
these three days suddenly mum the world
doesn't
shake anymore the walking aid simply gave me the
opportunity to take part in all of
them  I also travel as much as
I want and also go on
hikes in Brazil.
I would never have thought
of doing business here because of our own experience with
the disability.
If you then see other people with a
similar disability, of course it's
nice to roll
would that this knowledge be
passed on
to these people after the market launch, we want to go
into the  Expanding the European environs i
think will be relatively
easy for us because of the eu, which
supports it a lot,
but also because we have a lot of
inquiries from many other countries
i'm very proud of the way we've come, because they've
really come a long
way with  at the moment we find not
only mother and daughter yes actually
also commercial banks i miss love what
i have to do the rooms have
turned around a lot
[music]